-Our first guests tonight
are "New York Times"
best-selling authors
and the hosts of "Desus & Mero,"
which airs Thursday nights
on Showtime.
Please welcome back to the show
our friends Desus Nice
and The Kid Mero.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Gentlemen, this is my favorite
kind of week
because I have already
seen you this week.
-That's right.
We're revisiting.
-We're revisiting.
Yesterday, we filmed something
for your show, and you took me
to a New York institution.
-One of the
top cultural landmarks
in all of New York City.
-And based on the name,
I think people
who don't live in New York
would be surprised this is
a New York City institution.
-Right. It sounds like
a regional place, but it's not.
It's international
and in our hearts.
-Where did you take me?
-We took him to Dallas BBQ.
-That's right, baby.
[ Laughter ]
Dallas BBQ.
Know what I'm saying?
-And if you're not familiar
with Dallas BBQ,
it's where you can get
a 64-ounce margarita.
-Yeah.
-Why would you want
a 64-ounce margarita on
a Tuesday morning at 11:00 a.m.?
-Well, that's what we drank.
Everything --
It's Texas-style,
is how they describe it.
-Texas-style.
-They -- you could not lift
these with one hand.
-No, no, no, no, no.
-It's like holding a newborn.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You really work out your arms.
-Really did.
-There's so much sugar
in the drink --
that's why they do it --
so you can curl the drink
and burn calories.
-And often they come with
test tubes with an additional
shot of alcohol.
-That's right. But to keep it
classy, the small umbrella.
-There was a very --
yeah, there was --
we had a lot of umbrellas
littering our table
at the end of the day.
And I will say,
and I talked to both of you
backstage,
I feel like my hangover
was way more from the sugar
in the BBQ drinks.
-Oh, yeah.
-Absolutely.
-Oh, yeah, absolutely.
My pancreas is gone.
It's gone.
-That was your favorite
of the organs!
-I always bragged about it.
-Yeah, I'm so sorry.
-I like my appendix.
-But you know what?
You are a great person
to go drinking with.
-Thank you.
-You can handle your liquor.
You're not a lightweight.
-Nope.
-Give it up for our guy Seth.
-Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
I don't know if that's great.
-I don't know
if that's great, either.
-I don't know.
-It's like, "Eh, you drank
a gallon of
Long Island iced tea."
-It's cool when you get old
and you can still drink
like a 19-year-old, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Last time you were here,
we were talking about Eric Adams
and the potential
that he would be our mayor.
He's our mayor. How do you guys
think he's doing?
-Uh, it feels like we elected
a club promoter.
[ Laughter ]
-It does.
-He's my favorite mayor so far
that has their ear pierced.
There's nothing wrong with that.
-Yeah, that's true.
We got that going for us.
-He's also one of the only
mayors I feel like could bust
into a big D.J. session
in a nightclub.
So I'm looking forward to that.
-You guys have both said
that he basically governs
like someone who only has
24 hours in New York City.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
It's crazy how many places he is
over the course of one day.
-He just goes everywhere.
It's like he gets invites
in the e-mail that you would
usually be like,
"Eh, I don't want to do that."
He's just like, "Yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes."
-He's liking the invites
in his spam box.
-Yeah.
-He might show up
at your kid's bar mitzvah.
You don't know.
-He was at my kid's
sixth birthday party.
I don't know how
he got the invite.
-And then he wanted five
minutes, right?
He wanted to make a speech
about the vision.
-And then he left with
the bottle he came with.
[ Laughter ]
-Of Similac.
Why'd he take the Similac?
[ Laughter ]
-Obviously, a lot of people,
both who live
in New York City and don't,
know that we have a problem
with our subway system.
But there was a recent
improvement made.
There was $30 million
spent on a stairway.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-Were you guys excited about
this new beautiful stairway?
-Super excited.
-It's what we needed.
-It's just another
very long stairway
for you to get masturbated on
by a homeless person.
[ Laughter ]
Know what I'm saying?
-I mean,
some of us wanted new trains.
Some of us, you know,
wanted safety.
But they was like,
"No. Staircase."
-Staircase.
-"Enjoy."
-"Hey, man! You know that song
'Stairway to Heaven'?
Stairway to the Q train, bro."
[ Laughter ]
-Do you guys feel like
there's any solutions
to our subway problems
here in New York City?
-Like, I don't know.
Like, spend some of the money
that you guys
have in your coffers?
-Probably depends
what we think the problem is.
Is it trains running late?
Or perhaps --
'cause the other night,
I was drunk on a train,
and I was like,
"There's a lot of rats."
So if we release cats
to eat the rats...
[ Laughter ]
-Your solution is more cats?
-You'll hear more about it
when I run for mayor.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's not give it away yet.
Let's not give it away.
[ Applause ]
Just like, all of a sudden,
just that beautiful stairway
and just thousands of cats
descending.
-Meow!
-A lot of track fires.
-I talked to you guys about this
yesterday when I saw you.
You had a fantastic interview
with Denzel Washington
on your show.
And what was wonderful about it,
it was a side of him
that I feel like
we don't see that often.
He's obviously
a very serious man.
He's one of our greatest
living actors.
But he mostly just talked about
different train stations
in the Bronx with you guys.
-That was not Denzel Washington
the actor,
that was Denzel the New Yorker.
-Yeah.
-It's a whole different Denzel.
-"I'm D from Mount Vernon."
[ Laughter ]
-Did he warm into it,
or did he show up
like that immediately?
-He just came in there, 'cause
he knew we're from the Bronx --
BX all day --
and he's from Mount Vernon,
which is located
right above the Bronx.
So he already
felt that energy that, you know,
if you're not from New York,
it's the worst energy
you can ever see.
It's when two New Yorkers
link up together in a room.
-Oh, yeah.
-You're gonna hear a lot of loud
and a lot of, "Hey, we got pizza
in New York at 4:00 a.m.
You don't have that down here."
So, he just comes in,
and it was like hanging out
with your uncle.
He was just, like,
so conversational and just warm.
-Very chill.
He walked in, he saw the bodega,
he's like,
"I recognize this environment.
My guard is down."
-And then everything
Denzel says, he says it
with a certain gravitas,
so even if it's not serious,
you have to take it
really serious 'cause he's like,
"If you gonna get coffee,
get it light -- or sweet."
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "What?"
-All right.
-You just be on the train home,
like, "Denzel,
got to get it together, bro.
Can't be mixing these two."
-"Can't have a fluffernutter
with no peanut butter."
[ Laughter ]
But he says it with the grav--
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-He says it in, like,
a "Training Day" voice.
You're like, "Oh!"
-You're like,
"Okay, yeah, that's right.
Yeah, no, it's peanut butter
and marshmallow stuff.
Yeah, you're right."
-You guys did not have Rihanna
on the show, but you did have
a baby shower for her.
-We did.
-That was very nice.
-You know, 'cause we did that
thing where you throw people
a baby shower
that they're not invited to.
-Yeah.
-So she didn't show up.
-Did Eric Adams show up?
-I think so!
-He's there.
He's still there.
They already broke down the set,
he's still there.
-He was the one that pointed out
Rihanna didn't show up.
'Cause he was handling
the guest list.
-There you go.
-But you know Rihanna.
-Yeah, I've been --
you know, I had a wonderful --
I went day drinking with her,
much like I did
with you two gentlemen.
And it lives in my memory.
-Do you go day drinking a lot
with people?
-I do it more than I should,
yeah.
-I could tell you
that you need to stop that,
but what you need to do
is invite us.
-Yeah, next time,
I'll invite you.
Now, you guys, obviously,
you have not booked Rihanna,
but are you hoping
to be the first talk show
that has the baby on?
-Oh, yeah.
-I mean, you know,
maybe in utero, you know?
I mean, actually,
no, he's been born.
-It's too late. Yeah,
you missed that opportunity.
-We were trying
to get him in the warmer.
-The baby's not SAG yet.
We're waiting for all this
stuff, but it's gonna happen.
It's gonna happen.
-Gotcha.
That's obviously something
to look forward to.
You guys, you've talked,
as well, about wanting
to go to England and maybe
interviewing some royalty.
The Queen.
You want to start at the top.
-Right at the top.
Can't start with, like,
the babies.
-No, no, no.
-Got to go right for the top.
-No dukes or whatever.
Just like straight to the Queen.
-You're just gonna
go right into it.
-Yeah, you see how
we do interviews.
We make people comfortable.
-Yeah, that's true.
-Just imagine the Queen,
she takes the crown off.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-[ British accent ]
Blimey, blokes!
-Aye, mate!
Ay! Oi! Oi!
-Oi! You know who's
my favorite drill rapper?
[ Laughter ]
-Oi, you listen
to that new Skepta, mate?
-Her P.R. person's like,
"Queen, calm down."
-"We're gonna
have to heavily edit this."
[ Laughter ]
-That would be very --
I mean, you couldn't take
the Queen to BBQs,
I don't think.
-Oh, we would have to.
-We'd have to.
You know what?
I think you're afraid
that she would drink
more than you.
-I'm afraid --
[ Laughter ]
I think anyone that age,
if they had one sip of those,
they might drop dead.
-We're going to jail.
That's going to be
an international incident.
-I really have to speak
to the --
I've also never seen
that color of cocktail
that we had yesterday.
-Oh, no.
-Like you said, none of those
colors appear in nature.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
They are all man-made.
-Right, they all appear, like,
when there's
been a reactor leak.
-Yeah, yeah.
-A lot of those food dyes,
if you looked at
the bottle that they came in,
they were like
"Do not handle without gloves"?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-This is the first time I've
seen Jay Z blue in real life.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you guys follow
the jubilee, the big --
-[ Scoffs ]
Me and all the homies.
-Yeah, hell yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Jubilee, fam!
-A jubilee viewing party?
-At Dallas BBQs.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
We had our own jubilee.
-Oh, I saw this, the Ju-BB --
the Ju-BB-Lee.
-The Ju-BBQ-Lee.
-Yeah, the Ju-BBQ-Lee
viewing party.
And you guys hosted it.
-We hosted it,
and we dressed up
like Queen Elizabeth.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-And she didn't show up.
-Now, do you guys
get in trouble?
Can you get canceled for that,
dressing up
like Queen Elizabeth?
I think, like, you might
be in the clear, right?
-I mean, it depends on what kind
of look you pull off.
-Yeah.
-I feel like people would
just be like,
"Oh, they're Madea."
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there's a chance.
-I don't know if it would work.
-You know, if you see me
in compression stockings,
that might just be
'cause I'm old.
-Yeah, all right.
Well, we're all getting
a little bit older,
but it's still wonderful
to have you guys around.
Thank you so much
for spending time with us.
-Thank you, Seth!
-I can't wait to see the show
this Thursday.
Desus Nice, The Kid Mero,
everybody!
"Desus & Mero" airs
Thursday nights on Showtime.
It's never anything
but fantastic.
We'll be right back
with Jensen Ackles.